[Music]
we are now
officially only one week away from e3
and
i gotta tell you my body is more than
ready
for this now i know we've been burned
before in the past where we expected
breath wall 2 to show up and it just
didn't however with all the rumors
floating around paired with the fact
that aonuma promised we would see the
game later this
year i am more than confident that this
might be the one where else then on the
big stage at e3 would be a better time
e3 and zelda has become sort of a
tradition at this point
2002 2004 2010 2014 16 and of course
2019 and i'm sure i'm forgetting even
more after the dumpster fire that was
2020 which left us without an e3
altogether
i think we are now ready ready to hear
what happened for what feels like 100
years ago since they announced this damn
game
although i am confident that the sequel
will show up at this year's presentation
i don't think it's going to be as
massive as a blowout as some people are
speculating
i expect something similar to 2016 with
breath the wild
a bigger better trailer with gameplay
footage this time around
a title reveal so we can hopefully
finally stop calling it breath of the
wild too
and maybe a release date or at the very
least a release year if they're not yet
ready to make promises on that front
so to give this hype train one final
boost before entering the weekend of
june 12
i'm gonna do one last breath of the wild
two theory slash
prediction and when i say prediction i
of course mean wild guesses since we
cannot really know anything
so join me as we take one final look at
a gameplay possibility for the legend of
zelda
the smirgo bob chronicles title
copyrighted by nintendo
[Music]
ever since the game's reveal there's one
topic that has stood out among zelda
videos at least when it comes to
gameplay possibilities which is
of course the underground right after
the e3 reveal
anuma stated that he wanted to revisit
this rendition of hyrule something that
left some people
a bit worried since as vast as the
overworld was
pretty much every nook and cranny of
this landscape has been scrutinized in
the past 4 years
what else is there to do at this point
more quests a new story event and yet
even more shrines will probably not be
enough to avoid the game from feeling
like the dlc it was originally intended
to be
so naturally once we saw lincoln zelda
traversing a vast cave we concluded that
hyrule may have a wide array of caves
underground ruins and maybe even entire
subterranean cities to explore
another widely discussed idea is
underwater exploration
and for good reason many zelda games
have featured it in the past
horizon is doing it for its sequel and
given the fact that breath the wild was
all about player freedom not being able
to venture beneath the waves of hyrule's
lakes and oceans was definitely one of a
few restrictions that clashed with the
open world design philosophy
apart from petting dogs and no i'm never
gonna let this go
who's a good boy who's your good boy
you are yes you are alright alright i'm
gonna let this go
for now so we have underground and
underwater
both of which feature descending down on
the z-axis assuming the zelda team won't
expand the map beyond its current
borders that leaves us with one more
direction to go
after all the z-axis doesn't only go
down but up
as well now i'm definitely not the first
to pitch this
idea people have been calling for the
return of loft wings or returned to
skyloft and even outer space in some
cases since the very beginning but what
i want to do today is show you some
interesting speculation
hints and observations that other people
have pointed out to me in the past weeks
as well as give you some of my own takes
on the matter that shows that gameplay
featuring aviation
could be a possibility because when you
think about it
for a game that calls itself open air
rather than the traditional
open world there wasn't really all that
much to the sky
in breath of the wild sure paragliding
around was nice
but other than that it's mostly just a
case of holding forward on the control
stick
airborne enemies were often conveniently
hovering only a few feet off the ground
the only exceptions were the floating
platforms which were only present in
master mode and part of dlc pack 1 and
some very specific scripted events such
as
entering valmeado and the fight with the
malice-infested nadra both of which
required the use of perpetual updrafts
which weren't there under normal
circumstances
and this is not meant to be a criticism
of breath of the wild there was a lot to
explore on the surface which is where
the main focus lies the paraglider was
there to make traversal faster
more fun to do and encourage climbing to
high places and finding vantage points
back in 2017 its inclusion was pretty
novel
rarely had we seen this level of freedom
before being able to glide around from
anywhere to anywhere was amazing but as
was to be expected since then
other games have started to implement
similar mechanics like gentian impact
and even horizon forbidden west recently
revealed a similar feature
because of this and the fact that breath
the wild is four years old now the
mechanic
doesn't feel as special anymore but as
stated before this
isn't about breath the wild but it's
sequel and for the sequel we need more
than just a few new landmarks to explore
so next i want to talk about a few
things a the means by which link can
take flight
b the possible story implications and
see some additional gameplay elements
that could come into play
if this is realized the paraglider was
designed to slowly descend
not ascend so it either needs to get an
upgrade that does allow link to soar
upwards like rivale's go except not
restricted to a single grounded boost
or a completely new power mount or
device to do so
one option i discussed with andre's
restart on his podcast not too long ago
was the return
of loftwings i've been very skeptical
about the idea of loftwing's returning
since nintendo rarely brings back
central mechanics from previous titles
there are exceptions like phantom
hourglass revisiting wind waker sailing
but this doesn't happen often the wall
merging mechanic from a link between
worlds the mass transformations from
majora's mask wolfling travelling by
train
none of these have ever made a return in
the same way that's kind of the way
nintendo rolls
they come up with a unique central
mechanic and then it's gone afterwards
some may see this as a negative but at
the same time it's also what still gives
the zelda series its right to exist
even after more than 20 installments
however there is one thing that made me
more open to the possibility of
loftwings that being the recent
introduction of the loftwing amiibo now
do i think loftwings will play a central
role in breath of the wild 2
no but it could at least be possible
that it will unlock something extra and
before you start sweating because you
can't or won't buy the loftwing amiibo
i'm not saying that this will be the
only way to obtain a loft wing
instead you could compare it to a pona
who was only available through amiibo
but
other horses still exist so perhaps the
amiibo will unlock link's crimson
loftwing from skyward sword as a reward
for buying the amiibo
if loftwings were to make a return in
breathtak 2 this would be only one of a
few times that nintendo has brought back
a core mechanic from a previous game but
in this case i think it would be totally
justified
because as those of you who've already
played skyward sword know this was a
very underdeveloped aspect of the game
ever since the review of skyward sword
the main selling point which got the
most attention beside the motion
controls was flying around on your bird
but there wasn't really all that much to
it there were no enemies to fight in the
sky
heck link couldn't even use any of his
weapons while airborne
all the loftwing was good for was
landing on things and as a way to reach
the surface
that's it i think breathtak 2 could do
so much more with this concept
that being said this doesn't mean it has
to be achieved through the use of loft
wings of course
there are other alternatives an obvious
one would be a return to the sheikah
tech once more
the master cycle zero demonstrated the
superiority of the shika technology for
traverso
on land so what if this time around link
obtains a new vehicle that can fly
perhaps built by robbie or pura a device
which can be upgraded as you progress
through the main story similar to the
master cycle it may require fuel and at
first the amount of air time you can get
out of it is limited but similar to the
stamina gauge
upgrades can make it fly longer or
higher as you go
in creating a champion we can see that
nintendo was initially thinking about
the inclusion of vials or
syringes filled with ancient energy by
the looks of it they were meant to power
the sheikah slade but i guess that got
scrapped to make use of the slate more
convenient without having to fill it up
each time but for a vehicle
portable and obtainable ancient energy
would make perfect sense
another option which we already got a
very brief glimpse of could be link's
magic spirit arm
we still have no idea what this means
for the gameplay but if we do some wild
speculation here
what if this is what grants linked the
power of temporary flight it could
either manipulate link's paraglider
allowing him to ascend while
gliding or perhaps link won't even need
a paraglider and the hand allows him to
superman his way around for short
periods of time i know this sounds crazy
but
i mean whatever this being is it seems
to house itself
or its power into link and if this being
turns out to be a sage or maybe
even a twilight both of which have shown
to be able to hover or fly
perhaps this ability is bestowed upon
link similar to how rivali's essence
gave him access to his ability this also
got me thinking
if you look closely at the teaser link
seems to be keeling backwards as the
hand latches on to him
this could of course mean nothing but at
the same time what if this is how it
saves link and zelda in this scenario
it's pretty clear that the two are in
serious danger of falling down the
bottomless pit surrounding ganon's
corpse
so what if they do fall down and the
hand saves them by giving link its power
of flight this could mean that during
this shot link is either
already falling possibly with zelda
right below him and he gains the power
mid-fall so he can save her
and himself or he's in the process of
going over the edge at this moment
either way similar to the shika flying
machine this power
obviously has to be limited maybe it
runs on magic which means we could see a
return of the magic meter
upgrading the meter would then mean
being able to fly for longer
so these are a few possibilities as to
how so now let's go over the why
why would link need to fly if there's
nothing to do in the sky anyway
some floating platforms and flying
enemies are certainly not
enough for such a huge addition to the
gameplay well as you've probably guessed
the rising hyrule castle could
definitely have something to do with it
which is also where i need to address
something that bannon pointed out to me
on twitter he claims that the castle
isn't the only thing rising up in the
final shot but an area called the
bottomless swamp as well
now i gotta be honest this might just be
part of the overworld fog we often see
rolling around in hyrule's landscape but
if you look closely you definitely do
see a pretty significant
cloud rising up in this area at the same
time the castle is rising up there's
also a big cloud formation in front of
the castle which would approximately be
where the central chica tower would have
been again could be nothing more than
just some random clouds which just so
happen
to form at this exact moment but it's
not too crazy to think that hyrule
castle isn't the only thing rising but
instead multiple sections of hyrule will
take to the skies
creating an entire cluster of floating
islands above the map and leaving
enormous craters where they once
were i'd also like to point out that
it's a bit weird that the screen is
shaking so viciously when whatever is
happening to the castle
is that far away in fact the shaking
doesn't start until way later perhaps an
indication that the great plateau itself
which is where this footage is taken
from
is about to rise up as well i definitely
love the idea of multiple floating
islands and not like in skyward sword
where they were mostly just a bunch of
floating rocks
i mean actual big chunks of land with
waterfalls
vegetation maybe even entire villages
that got taken to the sky with it
i mean can you imagine the shock the
people of hatano village or the gorons
would endure if something like this were
to happen to them
one little hint to the possibility of
multiple floating islands is the concept
art shown at the gdc
the one where ganondorf is standing on a
giant floating landmass
and as you may notice this is not the
castle floating but rather seems to be
death mountain we of course can also not
forget the mothership high up in the sky
with smaller vessels around it
not saying aliens will be the main bad
guy i doubt we'll get ganondorf
and aliens but it at least shows that
the team was toying around with enemies
high up in the sky
it could be that vametto was the
replacement of that idea but
i just want to cover all options and
speaking of vametto
age of calamity already gave us a taste
of some airborne combat in the vametto
sections
and i don't know about you but i thought
these were pretty darn cool
your range of motion was severely
limited as was the area you were allowed
to fly in but it at least shows that the
vast open space above hyrule's map lends
itself for huge aerial battles
so in terms of story it could be that
ganondorf rips parts of hyrule asunder
and elevates them to the sky
each of these islands could be hovering
at different elevations and thus the
journey to ganondorf's castle could be
hindered by how far your powers and gear
allow you to ascend
upwards meanwhile back at the surface
new challenges are awaiting as well
perhaps the craters left behind by the
land that rose up reveals underground
caves which could tie into the
underground stuff
add to that the possibility of
underwater traversal and subtly
revisiting the same map again
doesn't seem as redundant anymore this
world would be turned on its head and
new provinces wouldn't even be necessary
an example of a story progression in
this case would be that as ganondorf
took himself and parts of hyrule to the
sky you are basically stuck on the
ground at first
unable to do much which would be similar
to the great plateau in breath the wild
where link was stuck
until he obtains the paraglider and you
can start the main quest proper
in this case you wouldn't be able to
leave the surface until you obtain your
first ability to fly be it a loft wing
ashika vehicle or the green spirit hand
which then at first allows you to visit
some of the
lower hanging islands from there you
advance further and further upwards by
beating dungeons upgrade your power to
fly and obtain new abilities
speaking of which let's lastly do a
quick dive into some additional gameplay
options which could work well with the
idea of aviation
obviously a hook shot or grapple hook
would make a fine addition to this
i've already talked about something like
this in the past but something that
worried me was being able to hit
exact targets while falling or flying
might be a bit too difficult then i
suddenly remembered another mechanic
which was introduced in breath the wild
the bullet time being able to slow down
time mid-air would give you ample amount
of time needed to hit your targets
other mechanics could include the option
to actually use your weapons while
flying
something which wasn't possible with the
paraglider since link needed both hands
to hold on
being able to deploy a small flying
device similar to the beetle something
we have seen nintendo contemplating on
two occasions
in creating a champion maybe the hens
power can give link a double jump
similar to rox cape from minish cap to
get some extra distance
or creating your own platforms in the
air like the cloud power-up from mario
galaxy 2.
the list goes on now it could be that
all the stuff i'm describing is
way too ambitious and it isn't without
its problems either
we've seen how in breath the wild people
were able to utterly break the game by
abusing the physics engine
stuff like this would definitely make
sequence breaking the game a breeze
given that it has a certain order in
which you need to complete the main
story
so either these glitches if you can call
them that need to be removed or
since these were made possible because
of the sheikah slate the slate itself
would have to be retired it would of
course be amazing if we get it all
skye underwater and underground but like
i said that might be asking a bit too
much and i definitely don't want to set
anyone up for disappointment here
but we can dream can't we one thing's
for sure in order for the sequel to live
up to the hype and surpass the game of
the year winning breath of the wild
we're gonna need more than just some new
quests and new areas to what degree
that remains to be seen and that my
friends is the last of my thoughts and
speculations on breath of the wild 2.
now watch as this video becomes totally
irrelevant in one week's time
but hey at least we had fun coming up
with ideas these last two years
as you might expect this will be my last
video until after e3 is over however i
will be streaming the nintendo
presentation together with some of my
friends so i hope you will join me then
as we will make sure it will be a hype
and entertaining broadcast
until then this is dawn signing off
and have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
you